The wallflowers at bath and Body Works can be a little bit pricey.
So here is my little hack for when they're not on sale.
I go to Walmart and I grab these Better Homes and gardens refills.
I unscrew the plugins and the toppers from each of the bottles.
I grab some pliers.
It can take some work,
but I gently remove just the wig,
set it aside, and then do the same thing with the new bottle.
Then I'm gonna pour the oil from the new bottle into the old one.
And I'm very, very careful.
You don't wanna spill any of this.
You don't wanna get it on your hands.
I actually recommend wearing gloves if you can.
And then I'm gonna put the new Wick into the bottle,
and you want about this much to be sticking out.
And then I'm gonna screw back into the plug in.
I've been using these for years,
and yet I always forget to screw it the opposite direction at first.
But there you have it.
These ones are about half the price of the bath and Body Works refills.
And I refuse to buy them when they aren't on sale.
So this is what I do in the meantime.